welcome to PlayStation VR okay you
hooked up your PS we are now it's time
to get ready to play some games set up
your PlayStation camera where it'll have
a good view of the entire play area
mounting it on top of your television is
usually best but you can also set it up
at the base of your TV with either
placement be sure the camera is not
obstructed and is able to read the
headsets tracking lights as well as the
lights on your ds4 or move controller at
all times while you're enjoying your
psvr
you'll need to establish a play area of
6 feet by 10 feet the cameras position
should mark the centerline of your play
area which looks like this for your
safety
you'll need to clear out all of the
furniture toys exercise equipment pets
and other obstacles before you put the
VR headset on for added safety and peace
of mind you should create a nice buffer
zone outside the play area it's also a
good idea to stay seated while enjoying
your VR experience the 9 tracking lights
on the PS VR headset track your movement
in correlation with the camera during
your virtual reality experience if you
happen to stray outside of the play area
you'll receive a pop-up warning
prompting you to return to the suggested
location within this designated space
try to limit any light sources directly
behind you they might throw off the
headsets tracking capabilities it's also
a good idea to close any curtains or
shades now it's time to get you in the
game keep your controllers handy and put
your stereo headphones on if you're
using on ear or over ear headphones
these go on over the PS VR headset
you'll likely be doing things like
fighting intergalactic Wars and
defeating ancient evil so you want your
headset to have a snug but comfortable
fit there are two main buttons you'll be
using to adjust the size and fit of the
headset the scope adjustment button
located under the scope on the bottom
right side and the headband release
button first use the scope adjustment
button to extend the scope then press
the headband release button to extend it
and adjust the fit with the headset now
on use the adjustment dial and back to
fine-tune the size the scope adjustment
button helps the fit by allowing you to
pull the scope inwards towards your face
so you can easily place it where it's
the most comfortable to take the headset
off simply press the headband release
button again if you wear glasses just
put the headset on over them be sure to
use the scope adjustment button to bring
in the scope for a comfortable fit
around your glasses the first time you
use psvr the headset will need some
adjustments just do what our little
friend here tells you in the psvr as you
I set up he knows what he's doing to
recalibrate or change your settings
later on press and hold the PS button on
your controller to bring up the quick
menu and select adjust PlayStation VR or
go to the settings menu for more
settings options if you want to play a
normal ps4 game or watch a movie you can
use cinematic mode for the best
experience to enjoy cinematic mode you
may need to reset your screens position
to do so face forward in the direction
you are sitting and then press and hold
the options button to reset the screen
position into its ideal place
once everything is calibrated you're
good to go now launch a VR game and
enjoy the PS VR experience